live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions it's the ramsey show where
debt is dumb cash is king and the paid
off home mortgage has taken the place of
the bmw as the status symbol of choice
we help people build wealth do work that
they actually love and create real
amazing relationships george campbell
ramsey personality host of the entree
leadership podcast is my co-host today
as we answer your questions about your
life and your money open phones at
triple eight eight two five five
two two five that's triple eight eight
two five
five
two two
five
taylor is going to start off this hour
in albuquerque new mexico hey taylor
what's up
hello how are you doing better than i
deserve how can i help
um so i am debt free but i am afraid to
invest i like knowing that i have an x
amount of dollars a bank or of money in
my account and that'll only change if i
spend it
but i would like to purchase or even
possibly
build a home and start a snowball
investment with a rental property
but the house i own right now wouldn't
be a good rental and i'm just not sure
where to start to not be house broke
okay so you own a house now do you owe
money on the house that you live in
no good what's it worth
um about 130 000 good for you and what
do you make a year
growth or net either
um net 43 000. okay
how did you get 130 000 house paid off
um i got it gifted and divorced oh well
there's that okay
good deal so what are you looking to buy
you said you've got some money in the
bank but you're scared to put it into
real estate
yeah so i i don't know how real estate
works really and i never
bought a house all the houses that i've
had have been just i sign on the line
and now i have a house because that's
what my ex-husband did
so i just don't know like where to start
how to get into rentals
okay
how old are you
31. what do you do for a living
um i'm an office manager at an oil and
gas company okay good for you
all right well in in
buying a rental house uh not knowing
anything about real estate is dangerous
that's why you're hesitant that's why
you're hesitant
so you need to you know do some
you need to engage in
uh some kind of a process to learn about
being a landlord and learn about what
all is entailed with that
uh because you don't wanna you don't
wanna learn this is not a
learn-on-the-job thing okay you wanna
know what you're getting into
so you might get in touch with some real
estate people you might get in touch
uh with some training on how to properly
put the right kind of tenant in the
property how to interact with the
tenants so that you get paid
um because i don't want them to perceive
the tenant to perceive that you're
someone they can take advantage of
because you don't know what's going on
right because that that perception would
lead to rent not being paid we're not
going to do that okay
yeah i've done that before
so you know you need to come at this
from a position of strength and the
knowledge will give you the confidence
and the strength to do that at that
point then i'm going to start saving up
and paying cash for
a rental again how much cash do you have
uh about 45 000 okay all right so you're
not ready today anyway
so we would tell you to pay cash for any
properties but certainly for
for uh investment properties and so
you might kind of start poking around
going okay what can i buy for a hundred
or
uh you know whatever in the albuquerque
area and what what kind of tenant does
that mean i'm going to be dealing with
and is this what i want to do then
and so while you're saving from 40 up to
100 above your emergency fund you need
to keep an emergency fund i would engage
in learning to give you the confidence
to do this now dave we talk about trying
to find a deal you don't want to pay you
know market or above in an investment
property are there certain parameters
you'd say hey if you can buy it for 100
and rent it out for a thousand is there
a certain percentage that makes sense
well i mean uh
that is kind of an old rule of thumb
that you can probably rent it per month
for one percent
you know but you can't always it doesn't
always work that way so you need to
investigate what that property will rent
for
um and
uh
then
you know i'm always looking to buy
considerably under
the quote appraised value unquote
uh and so you know what all is that
going to mean in her situation
so
it's going to take her some time to
build up her her money to do this with
and during that time she's got um
really going to have to in a sense go to
real estate school do some homework in
in informally informally go to real
estate school and learn about
landlording learn about property and you
know investing
uh it's not super complicated but it's
not something you want to walk into with
having done no
uh
prep none whatsoever
michael's with us in dallas hey michael
welcome to the ramsay show
hello dave hey what's up
um i'm a first time caller my wife
actually called you in 2009
doing a debt-free scream on our behalf
cool
my question is regarding legacy and
making a will
my wife and i currently don't have wills
and the reason
is that
we're in some disagreement on what to do
and our disco agreement is related to
our children our children are both
adults
out of school they're 29 and 33
and both of them their lives are a hot
mess
we both
we both agree not to
leave them our money
i want to leave our mind to the church
she wants to leave it to sporadically
different family members because she's
made
really close to her nieces and nephews
and their children
so we just need some guidance
okay neither one is wrong
neither is wrong we consider making
wills but i don't want to go
we don't really want to go separate from
each other and that's the difficulty
that we're having
no you shouldn't um because you're gonna
leave probably leave everything to her
she's probably gonna leave everything to
you and the only thing that comes up
with all this other stuff is the second
to die
yes that's the easy part i just don't
want
whoever dies last wins kind of like that
that's one way to do it
game of thrones baby here we go
i mean could you split the difference
could a portion go to the church and
abortion go to family
um that is a possibility actually we
we recently watched um the legacy
journey
and after the one the segment on making
a will i'm leaving a legacy
we've probably had the biggest fight
that we've had in 10
wow
years
it was related to this issue yeah
well i'm glad we could help
[Laughter]
yeah i think i think george is on to
something i think some compromise is in
order there's no moral
issue with either of the things there's
no ethical issue with either of the
things
and i think both of them are actually
valid and if i were in your situation
i'd probably want to do a little both
and splitting it down the middle or you
know
it doesn't have to be down the middle
but some of each
is a really really good
move that's a real good plan
thank you michael appreciate you
listening
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
chaos
that's what it can feel like when your
business is growing so fast you've
outgrown your financial and accounting
software the faster you grow the more
likely you are to lose control of the
numbers and here's the reality if you
don't know your numbers you don't know
your business that's why we use netsuite
by oracle the number one cloud financial
system over 28 000 companies use
netsuite by oracle including ramsey
solutions because netsuite gives us a
single view of everything we need to
make daily decisions whether you're
making a few million to hundreds of
millions a year netsuite gives you the
visibility and control of the things you
need to grow like your financials
inventory hr planning budgeting and more
all in one dashboard go to netsuite.com
ramsey right now to get their free white
paper jump start your cfo career
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
george campbell ramsey personality is my
co-host today
and uh one of his good friends and my
new friends graham stefan has dropped by
uh
big time real estate youtube guy
everybody knows who he is netflix famous
oh yeah four million subscribers on
youtube that's pretty impressive it is
it's uh and it's incredible to be here
because i really feel like i
got a lot of my start watching you and
you were the one that really forged a
path on youtube before i even started uh
so seeing you do it first gave me almost
the permission that wow maybe i could do
it too yeah and and then the weird thing
is i actually didn't forge anything it
was just youtube versions of this show
it was just youtube watching in while we
do this show that's all i did and and
our youtube team
clipping that stuff up and running it
around but uh graham got his real estate
license at 18 years old he sold over 130
million dollars of residential real
estate he owns a bunch of real estate i
won't say how much i happen to know
because of some stuff we taped earlier
today but uh has done very very very
well in the real estate world and is uh
well known okay so i got my real estate
license when i turned 18 too three weeks
after i turned 18 years old my parents
were in the business though yours
weren't what inspired you to get into
the business the truth is that i didn't
have good grades in high school because
i just wanted to work and when i didn't
get into college i thought i have to do
something for myself i want to get into
doing something where i could be my own
boss and i thought well i could just go
into real estate i get my real estate
license and so as i was getting my
license i go to open houses talking to
other agents and in the process i just
fell in love with it as a career so once
i got licensed i began working at
coldwell banker and just instantly i was
obsessed with it it's all i wanted to do
i just wanted to work and so for those
first really four to five years i would
work seven days
10 to 12 hours a day but it never felt
like work and that's what i loved about
it is that i could see incredible
properties meet people that i would
never ordinarily come into contact with
make great clients friends connections
it just the opportunity was limitless
so when i got my license at 18 um
i had like a suit that didn't fit real
well and one suit the other suit was
like a disco suit
and these were my dress-up clothes to go
show houses in and i had like a tom
selleck mustache you remember magnum p.i
you know please bring it back dave bring
up the ferrari
and because i thought it made me look
older right because i knew i was just a
pup
and i still
had trouble getting people to take me
seriously because i was so stinking
young
did you run into that
oddly no but i think a lot of people
gave me a chance because i was so young
so starting at 18
and i look young now even i'm 32 and you
know i still get like early 20s or i
could i'm sure i could pass
but i think in that sense they saw that
i was really dedicated to helping them
and i would do anything and that was my
advantage i think early on is that i
would take the deals no one else wanted
to take and i saw that as my opportunity
that there's all this business out there
that isn't worth anyone else's time but
when i'm 18 like earning a few hundred
dollars a big deal for me and so i would
take on that business
and i would work 24 7. so if they call
me at two o'clock in the morning i'll
get back to them i'll pick up the phone
i would pick up the phone if i'm
sleeping at night uh it didn't matter
i'd respond to emails at midnight
so i would do anything and i think
because of that
people felt comfortable and they knew
that i also wasn't sophisticated enough
to like ever screw anybody over so they
knew i could never take advantage of
them i couldn't lie to him i couldn't do
anything besides just do my best and
that's what i did
so
how old were you when you bought your
first piece of investment price 21. 21
you bought your first rental house and
you paid cash for it cash yeah that
means you were making some money as an
agent yes
yeah i really did my best to save as
much money as i could and uh you know in
the beginning i saved because i didn't
know when my next commission was going
to be and so sometimes i would go a few
months without earning a dollar but i
was working like 12 hours a day and
other months i'd make a lot and so
because i didn't know i just figured
well my default should just be saving as
much as possible
and i just continue doing that and just
focusing on work but saving and then
when i got to a point this was 2011 the
market had really i felt bottomed and i
started noticing some of my clients
beginning to buy like the smartest guys
that i knew began buying real estate and
i had this money saved up and i thought
well if they're all doing this too maybe
there's something to it and so i started
spending my time uh you know alongside
helping clients is well now i'm gonna
look for myself and let me see all these
properties and figure out an area that i
could buy in and that's what led to that
your youtube viewers know you as being
frugal jack your co-host says you're
cheap
um
so
uh
i mean
is all you do is like working pile up
money i mean what do you do you have a
life
uh i love my work and that's
i would say 90 of the time i just want
to work um i don't like sometimes
saturdays it's uh it's hard for me
because the market's closed i love just
being involved like making videos i love
it so much that like that for me is fun
so i don't really feel like i need much
other than just being able to work
um as far as expenses go i mean it's
a lot is discretionary um
all you can eat sushi i would say is my
big treat is like wow 30 all you can eat
sushi in las vegas notoriously you don't
spend money on coffee you prefer to make
it at home you'll use old coffee and put
it in the fridge i bought you some iced
coffee this morning because i knew you
were struggling and so that was my
donation to you thank you but the reason
we struck up this friendship was because
we reacted to one of your tick tock
videos where you were talking about how
the best financial move you ever made
was living on less than you make and
that has been one of our principles
since dave started 30 years ago where
does that come from why are you not out
there living the flashiest of lifestyles
just dropping money left and right
i always just i think i naturally
enjoyed just saving money it was a weird
sort of obsession of mine where i felt
like you know that was something i had
direct control over how much money i was
to save and i took it almost like a
challenge to see like how could i cut
back and how could i optimize my
spending to get the best bang for the
buck and a lot of that was think it was
strategic it's you know
could i would go out for dinner or i
could make the dinner at home and my
experience was just as good if i have a
friend over or you know if if i'm going
out i'll get an appetizer instead of an
entree because it's just as filling but
it's you know half the price so i just
find all these little ways to save
and i just it became a habit but i
enjoyed it i think part of that was like
figuring out like you asked me earlier
what what the the most frugal thing that
i would do and it was using grocery bags
as trash bags instead of spending money
on trash bags i didn't want to do it
because i have the grocery bags i don't
want i don't want to waste them i'm
going to throw them away and they work
just as well so now you're a minimalist
now it's trendy and now it's trendy yeah
but now we gave it now we gave it our
friends gave it a name that's it so good
stuff graham stefan is our guest this
segment he has one of the top youtube
shows on real estate and finance over
almost 4 million folks subscribing be
sure and check him out there on youtube
and we'll be on a coming episode someday
out there
that we worked on today uh this morning
before we got on the air here so rich
people are all selfish and greedy
and they only look out for themselves
you ever heard that one all the time
all the time
i personally believe that and not not
all the time but just
in a broad sense that people are off
they often make money in proportion to
the amount of value they provide so i've
always seen it in terms of how many
people i could reach is is how much
value i'm providing
and a lot of what i talk about is really
just living below your means investing
consistently and thinking of different
ways to improve yourself financially and
that's just also what i'm personally
obsessed with so
i just talk about things that i am
personally doing and find enjoyment in
and try to add an entertaining spin to
things
that's one of our core values here is
marketplace service if you help enough
people you don't have to worry about
money and i don't see any evil in that
inherently you seem like a nice guy to
me thank you so there you go you gotta
pass the test thank you but you really
you're helping a lot of young people
especially who are wanting to build
wealth and they're not wanting to do a
job they hate and wait 35 years to have
money now part of that leads to a lot of
people being broke right how do you kind
of guard against that when you're giving
advice oh gosh i feel like there's a way
to do it safely and smartly that's not
like hypey i
i i'm personally not the one to like
risk it all i i'm actually fairly risk
adverse and i really prefer to to take a
safer approach where i just don't like
losing money so if i could you and they
have that in common that's for sure yeah
so if for me losing money is so much
more painful than making so i like i try
to steer away from losing and if we can
improve in one way it's uh you know
making sure you keep what you have
thanks for dropping by my friend thank
you i really appreciate it i'm honored
to have you with us graham
graham stephen ladies and gentlemen be
sure and check him out on his youtube
channel you will be visiting him with
about four million of his closest
friends this is the ramsay show
[Applause]
[Music]
look i love real estate and i want you
to have a house but i don't want a house
to have
you
that's why you need to get in touch with
churchill mortgage to make sure you do
this right these guys are awesome
they'll help you get on a smarter
mortgage plan because they're committed
to doing what's right for
you
that means they check in every year with
free consultations to help you stay on
the right plan they show you how to save
money and interest so you can build
wealth faster they walk you through the
total cost of your loan so you can make
the best choice
basically they care that's why we call
them ramsey trusted you can achieve
debt-free home ownership and churchill
is here to help go to their site
churchillmortgage.com
ramsey to start your approval or get
more information
[Music]
[Music]
george campbell ramsey personality
my co-host today
in the lobby of ramsey solutions bridget
is with us hi bridget how are you hi
dave how are you welcome where do you
live i'm living in kailua hawaii but uh
originally from new york oh wow well
welcome to nashville a bit of a hall
from hawaii to get here
but we're glad you're with us how much
debt did you pay off 162 253 dollars and
19 cents excellent how long did that
take 20 months and 60s whoa
you were hauling what was your average
income or or what was your range of
income during that time um 76 thousand
to ninety thousand
okay i know it doesn't add up so he must
have sold something well i did sell a
white bmw convertible
for how much for thirteen thousand
dollars
um and then i also put every covid
stipend and every tax refund that i
received between 2020 and 2021 towards
all my debt as well
and then i also i'm active duty military
and so my housing is taken care of for
the most part
that was huge and you didn't have money
in savings or anything that you threw at
it um when i started i had about um
40 000
ish saved so that kind of got me started
um so you threw that at it as well yeah
i like everything
between all of that the math is starting
to work again okay good very impressive
okay so you really went radical i mean
you cleaned out your savings you took
all your uh all your coveted money
coming at you you're living uh for the
on the with the military on base no
housing cost you're doing everything to
squeeze squeeze squeeze squeeze every
drop out of this and went after it so
what happened 20 months ago that put you
on this path
um well i had heard about you first in
2012. um my mom had bought me the old
fpu kit that you guys used to have
and i just carried it around with me and
kept it in my closet i did baby step one
i did baby step three just kind of skip
two and ignored it
and then i was a general surgery
resident um and wound up leaving general
surgery
and i was always planning on just having
a bigger shovel my whole life and i was
kind of like i don't know if that bigger
shovel's ever going to happen and i
can't wait for that anymore
so i just took that fp kit down off the
shelf and i went through it in about
nine days instead of nine weeks
and yeah i would uh read the
the
money makeover book to my mom out loud
as we went through it um but yeah i just
i got to that point i just never want to
go back to that again you know and that
gazelle intensity that you always talk
about um i just feel like that's the
most important thing to paying off debt
and um that's what i had just that
feeling inside me that you were
completely yeah numbers the numbers tell
us you were wide open instant
transformation did it hurt getting rid
of the bmw convertible i assume that was
like your dream car well yeah i mean
actually it was one of those things that
taught me like nothing in this world is
gonna bring you that like thing you're
looking for
um
actually was another one of those things
that taught me that lesson but um yeah i
loved the bmw but at the same time this
was more important to me
and
i was i had actually called i put my
name down online for elp financial coach
and i was actually reading the bible
about josiah and how the first thing he
did was clear out the temple and he told
the priest like you have to make sure
the money is going to where the work
needs to be done and so i'm sitting
there reading about this and being like
i need to do something with my money and
then the guy called me i just put my
name online and i told him i i need help
you know i need a financial coach he's
like you don't need a financial coach
you graduate from medical school you
need to trust yourself you need to trust
dave ramsey and you need to sell your or
he told me to pay off the bmw that's
what you did so i paid off the bmw first
i had a ten thousand dollar loan on that
and then a couple of weeks later i was
like you know what i need to sell it now
so i sold it for more than i paid off
wow
yeah
josiah coming in the clutch yeah that's
awesome wow it's powerful did you say
you're in the military now yeah so i had
done um hpsp it's called the health
profession scholarship for med school
and uh so they paid for med school so
all my loans are not actually medical
student loans they're undergrad grad and
post back
but yeah i did started that in 2013 i
was
commissioned into the military and they
paid for med school and now i'm active
duty oh very cool thank you for your
service thank you for your support
so how long do you have to be in for the
med school to be wiped um so i have
for med school alone it's four years
but then with residency and kind of my
circuitous route um till
2028 right now so
yeah but someone that's listening that
wants to go to med school without any
debt med school debt can go if they
serve four years yes and they can um
yeah i would advise them to listen to
you on whether paying back time is
equivalent to being in debt that's
something that but you know i felt like
i wanted to be an officer um
you know and a physician so it's kind of
like i have two careers that's cool yeah
that's very cool good for you thank you
well done well done
so what do you tell people the key to
getting out of debt is
i think it's that gazelle intensity and
getting to that point where you never
want to go back to that again like you
always say and that like gut wrenching
just i can't live like this anymore
i think without that you just
kind of miss um
that that why that you need to get it
done
how does it how does it feel does you
feel like a weight off your shoulders
you just seem like you're just you could
levitate
yeah i mean i i had no plan about how i
was going to deal with you know my whole
life i graduated college in 2007 and um
had started out 30 000 and then went to
graduate school and i got bigger then
did a postback and i got bigger and i
just i didn't know where i was going to
start and i had no clarity
so
yeah and even paying off the debt it was
every day i would wake up and be like i
heard somebody the other day say they
wanted to make more payments to get it
done and that's how i was i just wanted
to get it done so badly
and i would count down the days i had a
timeline and when it's going to get paid
off
so yeah now that it's done i mean i want
to look forward to the next goal
obviously but i'm so happy that it's
over so you said you read the total
money makeover out loud to your mom uh
so she's here supporting you she is yeah
and so talk talk about having a
cheerleader like that in your corner
it's amazing she really paved the way
for me
in my life she was one who started the
dave ramsey principles
and i kind of watched her
live them out that's why i caught on to
one and three
and so yeah just having her example in
my life and then being able to do it
together now and encourage each other
and we also coordinate um the virtual
classes oh thank you
yeah so and we do that together she's my
co-coordinator
coordinator for financial peace
university yes wow very cool good for
y'all good mom and daughter time right
there yes well spent great tag team yeah
great
well congratulations we're proud of you
thank you thank you david good work and
thank you for your service again very
very very well done good stuff
good stuff all right we've got a copy of
baby steps millionaires for you that was
the next chapter in your story
how ordinary people built extraordinary
wealth and how you can too
and i copy are also going to give you a
one-year membership to financial peace
university since you're coordinating
maybe you'll find somebody give that to
yes and they can go through and uh
you'll get to watch george and dr john
dolone and rachel cruz and me in the new
videos that came out recently
for that class it's uh upgraded
considerably so very well done and a
total money makeover book for you to
give away as well so thank you thank you
thank you thanks for everything very
well done and a long trip from hawaii to
get here to do your debt-free scream all
right it is bridgette from uh hawaii
162 000
paid off in 20 months that's the whole
thing together baby i mean she did it
all sold the beamer wow
making 76 to 90 and collected every
dollar she could every nickel out of the
corner of the couch count it down let's
hear a debt-free scream
three two one we're debt-free
[Applause]
wow that is awesome my face hurts from
smiling that just never gets old
wow that's cool that's cool
well there is something uh
magical about having a a parent support
you
when you're an adult
in doing something hard like this
because getting out of debt is not easy
it's hard
we never said it was easy we just said
it was worth it
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
george campbell ramsey personality is my
co-host we warned you guys if you want
tickets to attend any of our law of our
fall events you need to get them now
these events have been selling out
building wealth san antonio november
15th sold out
there's about 20 tickets left to the
second phoenix night on september the
12th it is almost sold out if you want
to go to phoenix you need to buy your
ticket today
dad gummit i told you we sold out the
first night we opened up a second night
get it done
and we've got a few tickets left to the
minneapolis event november the 10th and
then building wealth for the fall is
completely sold out wow when that all
happens so we're really really close on
that we of course have the uh october
22nd smart conference there's tickets
available for that the vip and the
platinum are already gone on that and
that's in dallas and so you get your
shot here folks october
september in phoenix november is
sacramento minneapolis san antonio only
they're all sold out except a few in
minneapolis so and just a few in that
phoenix september 12th tickets so good
times don't say we didn't tell you what
happens if someone always messages me
the day after we were in phoenix is when
are you coming to phoenix and we go oh
my gosh you weren't listening how in the
world yeah but that happened it does
happen
some fun events we love being on the
road again we missed you can you i
missed it can you help me i've been
telling you for
three months these tickets were not on
sale for 10 minutes they've been on sale
for months
so you need to get your tickets if you
want if you don't want to come it's okay
but if you want to come it's going to be
george and dr john dolone and ken
coleman and rachel cruz and i and um on
building wealth it's a good plan you
want to be there you don't want to miss
this it's good times
open phones here at triple eight eight
two five five two two five brian is with
us in columbus ohio hey brian what's up
hey dave it's a real honor to speak to
you i really appreciate you guys taking
my call today i i just want to say real
quick i love the graham stefan show also
so i'm looking forward to seeing you
guys on there oh thanks and uh just a
quick just a quick graham shout out
everybody that's watching right now
needs to baby step on that like button
there you go he's always talking about
hitting that like button
yeah yeah it's funny
so anyways my question is i want to have
someone some advice on talking to my
wife
about doing the baby steps we are so
close to being done with all of the debt
other than the house
and i just feel like if we got really
intense we could like in 12 months we
could probably knock it all out the only
thing we have any debt on it has wheels
um
so just and it's hard to convince 20
years of marriage down into a couple
sentences but i'll just tell you
when when we met and she moved in with
me but you know when we got married um i
was horrible with money i mean my
electric was about to be turned off she
put her whole paycheck on the electric
bill so we could have electricity and
it's just been a learning experience
from there she's great with money she's
great with you know paying the bills and
figuring out how to get it done
and i just i've kind of talked to her
about debt snowball and some of the
other things that you teach and i
get met with a little bit of resistance
like
hey i got this i know what i'm doing i
don't need i don't need anybody to tell
me what to do and you know kind of
almost like i don't need your help i'm
very much a
take charge kind of guy and i feel like
when i talk to her about this stuff i i
feel like she thinks i want to take over
and that's that's not the case i you
know i have no
no doubt that you know what you've been
doing is
22 years
interesting
is this the control thing is she
handling the finances right now
yeah she does the finances i mean you
know she shows me stuff but she does the
finances primarily well we need both of
you in this thing together and you need
to have a say because this is weak i
know i know and so part of part of this
is some of the hardest people to get uh
onto the baby steps are those who don't
feel like they're struggling with money
they feel like well i don't need that's
for people who are broke
but what you guys need to do is paint a
picture together of what the next 22
years of marriage look like and that
hopefully means no mortgage payment
we're retiring when we want to
because we've got a pile of money in the
bank and we don't know anyone anything
so right
what if we
i mean i don't know i think you just
sit down and say you know um
i deserve based on my behavior in the
past
for you to not listen to me about money
but
but
and i'm sorry for that
but i have been learning about this
stuff and it has been 22 freaking years
and so we um
you know what what i'm reading and what
i'm learning about it don't say dave
ramsey said whatever you do don't say
that okay um turn my name into a cuss
word in your house
but um but just say uh you know
the the stuff i'm reading the data says
that uh couples that work together
on their money you're obviously honey
you're more administratively minded than
i am and you actually executing a plan
that we've both agreed to
would be the best plan
but me not having any
say or input into this is not good for
our communication
and uh we're limiting
our potential i don't want to come in
here because i think you're bad at this
i want to come in here so that we're
working together
right because you don't think she's bad
at it
no not at all i mean she's she's gotten
us where we are i mean you know i can
attribute it you know i mean i i've done
a lot of hard work but she's done all
the stuff behind the scenes you know you
know with the financial aspect of it so
i don't think you're bad at this but the
data says
among millionaires that are in our
probability of winning in money and an
increased quality of relationship
is much better if we work together
and that does not mean that you've been
doing it poorly
it just means that we're both going to
talk about this and then you're going to
go execute what we've both agreed to
and that's what we need to talk about
doing
uh because she recently changed jobs
i'm sorry go ahead you're fine
um she recently changed jobs back to the
places she was working at before so
she's making more money and i kind of
got her to agree to
you know hey let's sit down and look at
what our income is and what our bills
are and all that stuff so i kind of got
her to agree to that she goes let me get
you know in the job and do that and you
know we'll take a look at it and all
that stuff i'm just you know well once
you once you've laid out a budget and
both of you are agreeing to it and both
of you can speak into it then that opens
up the possibility for other
conversations because here's the deal
jesus said your treasure is where your
heart is and when you can agree on where
your money's going
before it leaves
and then she writes the checks out or
she does the bill pay or whatever it is
when you are in agreement about where
your money's going what you're saying is
we've agreed on our value system we've
agreed on our fears
we've agreed on our dreams
we've agreed on the floor plan of the
house we're going to build
you don't think the bedroom is going to
be over there and i think it's going to
be over here we're in agreement on what
the house of our life looks like
and um that agreement
that's why so many people that go
through financial peace university come
back and say it saved our marriage it's
not a marriage class
but we force you to work together
because it's practical
and
it forces a level of communication on
life's most important things
where the money flows to is not it's not
the money that's important but where it
flows to
says what's important
you know you can read through your larry
briquette used to call it checkbook test
read through somebody's checkbook you
can tell what's important to them
you know and it's like uh fanduel
fanduel fanduel fanduel okay you're a
sports you have a sports betting problem
uh okay you know or it says uh you know
uh whatever it says target target target
target target okay you got a problem
with the big red target over there it's
it's it's eating your lunch um i mean
where what where you put money where you
spend your money where you spend your
time is
is a statement of who you are as a
person yeah so brian i'm gonna gift you
financial peace university my hope is
that she's at least willing to watch
those videos with you i hope it creates
some
shared common language and gives you
guys a vision for where you want to go
because right now it feels like we're
just maintaining but we're not going
anywhere and i want you guys to head in
the same direction and so hang on the
line austin's going to pick up and we're
going to gift you one year of financial
peace university and you can go through
those nine video lessons with her and i
hope that gets her on the plan and if
she's math-minded do some math and show
her how much money you're throwing away
at interest show her what those payments
could be if they stayed in your bank
account and what you could do with that
as a couple yeah that's the second stage
after the first stage of
first thing is we're first going to
agree that we're going to agree
that's a hard place to get to and if you
start there then you get to have a whole
lot of other discussions around it
it's good stuff
hey man thanks for calling in good
question
that puts this hour of the ramsey show
in the books our thanks to james andrews
zach ben and austin in the booth the
booth dudes they make it happen this is
the ramsey show
[Music]
do you love a good dave rant want to see
the latest ramsay show videos going
viral check out your favorite moments
from the ramsay show on youtube go watch
and subscribe to the ramsay show channel
on youtube
[Music]
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions it's the ramsey show where
debt is dumb cash is king and the paid
off home mortgage has taken the place of
the bmw as the status symbol of choice
we help people build wealth do work that
they actually love
and create amazing relationships
george campbell ramsey personality is
my co-host today open phones at triple
eight eight two five five two two five
josh is with us in columbia south
carolina hi josh welcome to the ramsey
show
thank you thank you very much for taking
my call sure what's up
so i'm 26 years old and i'm actually
about to start a new job in a new city
i've been living in apartments um for
the last three years i've been working
and i really like the lifestyle i'm not
really in a rush to be in a house but i
do know that i need to start thinking
about saving up for a down payment so
i'm trying to decide exactly how
aggressively i should be saving cash
versus investing into retirement
are you out of debt
yes sir okay fully funded
baby step three okay so you're there are
you investing yet yep
yes i've been um getting my full match
with my employer
also maxing my ross and
hsa
and that puts you at 15 decent head
start
does that put you at 15 yeah a little
bit over 15. okay i'd scale that back
down to 15 and then begin saving up cash
for that house and put that in a you
know high-yield savings account
somewhere you don't need to invest it
unless this is going to be you know five
plus years out but it sounds like you're
wanting to get in the house sooner than
that what's your game plan on getting in
a house what do you think
bill i i don't i'm single right now and
i'm not really interested in buying a
home uh you know before i'm married i do
have plans to get married in the next
you know 10 years or so
but like i said you know i'm really in
no rush um if i could guess right now
i'd say anywhere between
five and seven years i'd like to be
really thinking about being in a home
yeah i'm with george and i would lock it
in at 15 of your income into retirement
and i would start saving aggressively
above that
and just
pile it up for right now and let's just
stack cash
because um it it doesn't sound like that
you have selected the young lady or she
has selected you yet
that's right that's accurate kind of a
vague concept at this point what's your
income
uh i'm at 110. awesome yeah so point
being that
um this could flip uh
this could this whole environment could
change rather quickly
uh right and that's kind of exactly my
thought going into it which is why part
of me wants to you know have a little
more than just my emergency fund in cash
but yeah yeah i would pile up as much
cash above your emergency fund above
your 15 going into retirement as you can
you can't really save too much cash
in that situation
because um
you know you you've got it out there
somewhere in the future i'd like to be
married if i've met the right person and
so forth that's a good
good general sentiment but uh you know
when you meet the right person you might
be married a few months later that could
happen
and uh so uh you know by the next time i
talk to you this time next year you
could be married looking for a house i
don't know
uh that wouldn't be that unusual by the
way so i would set a specific goal and
not just make it i'm just gonna save up
money i would say i'm gonna aim to save
up twenty thousand dollars this year i'm
gonna say aim to save up twenty thousand
the next year five years i'll have a
hundred thousand dollars that helps you
have a game plan instead of just hoping
money gets saved exactly yeah you need
to have a set amount that you're going
for above the 15 and above the emergency
fund that's exactly what i would do hey
good question thank you for joining us
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five two two five george is with us
in monroe louisiana hi george how are
you
hey dave i'm fine thank you very much
good how can we help dave
well uh briefly i'm
25 in a house i've been living here
alone for 16 years there's four siblings
uh i'm one of the four two will allow me
to buy them out the fourth one refuses
to sell and she says she's moving in in
january she refuses to work
uh how my question how can i prevent her
from moving in if possible at all
if i owned three quarters at the time
and i don't at this point and number two
how can i force her to sell her part to
me or is it possible to do that
i don't know a mechanism that that you
can force her to sell
uh i'll
you could take the situation to court
and ask the court to solve this
90 of the time what's going to happen is
they're going to force the sale of the
house to split the money
yeah i i
assumed that the judge would not force
her to sell her apart from me correct
but he would he would he would force the
disillusionment of the partnership if
any one of the partners wanted it
dissolved
and the only way to do the only way to
liquidate it is to sell the house and
split the money four ways
yeah that's it gets kind of complicated
my
two siblings i i have 50 000 cash to pay
them but i've got a 401k with plenty of
money but i'm not going to borrow from
that nor am i going to cash it in so i
assumed that i would be able to get a
bank loan um
i don't understand how that works in a
sale if i purchased it myself in the
sale i'm not sure how that works
if it went up for sale
due to
uh the judge's order a court-ordered
disillusionment of partnership assets
then you could obviously be one of the
bidders
at that sale
and you just go get you can just go get
a mortgage and buy the house
okay uh uh well i wouldn't have the cash
money but the banks had a mortgage want
me
okay or the bank would front me the
money for a uh for those for a bid on
the house right because if it's an
auction yeah if it's a cash auction yeah
you'd have to have that set up yeah
i'll set up okay okay that's what i so
what your next step is uh you don't need
to screw around with this one day more
uh this is obviously a toxic situation
you need to go see an attorney today
yeah i just called one today and he's
supposed to get back with me i'm just to
see what we can do i want to try to get
my
other two siblings who are going to sell
get the paperwork done
and also get the paperwork done for the
fourth one she keeps changing her mind
back and forth so at least have it ready
yeah she's a manipulative game player
uh yeah well this threat to this threat
to move in is a game
yeah yeah i i probably can't stop her
from doing it it would not yeah you can
you can if you file an action
that's going to force the sale
oh okay that's the way to do it yeah do
you think she would be one of the
bidders looking to buy it
not shiny no she doesn't she doesn't
have any money she doesn't work that's
very brief
no she doesn't work she sold a house in
dallas five years ago for 225 000 she
moved here i told you you need to get a
job and buy pay cash for a house well
she said i don't want to work because
she's been living on that 225 now she's
down to 80 and she started getting
worried about it however she's going on
a 2 000 vacation here another week
so what i would do is talk to an
attorney and here's the way this is
probably going to go down okay
um the attorney's going to tell you that
you could file a
as a part of the as a part of the
lawsuit to keep her from living there
until the house is liquidated
because it's a toxic because it's a
toxic situation then you can go to her
and say i'm getting ready to file
this motion with the court a forced
liquidation of the house that will
simultaneously prevent you from moving
in
now
this is going to happen you're not
moving in and the house is going to be
sold
would you like me to buy you out instead
and you can force her hand on that and
then she's going to sign the deed and
you're going to enter a check and she's
going to go away
this is the ramsey shop
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
still on baby step number one
how'd you guess with health care costs
rising learn how christian healthcare
ministries can help you make the most
out of your budget visit
chministries.org
budget don't worry
it's worth it
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
george campbell ramsey personality is my
co-host today
so at this very moment every person
watching listening to the show has got a
different purpose and goal in life maybe
you want to find your ideal dream career
you want to cut up the credit cards and
work your way to building wealth well it
starts with you saying enough is enough
and we got to do something about this so
this is why we brought back the ramsey
10 sale on our number one best-selling
books but the sale ends at the end of
the month two days not a lot of time
left folks and i what you know what else
ends in two days dave the ramsey cash
giveaway that's a part of this so if you
want to jump start your journey here you
can enter that for your chance to win
the grand prize of three thousand
dollars and there's only two days left
don't miss this so two days to take
advantage of the ramsey ten dollar sale
most of our best-selling books are on
sale for ten dollars each
that's a bargain so you get ten of them
for a hundred bucks i mean that's uh
that's why i'm stocking up for christmas
inflation increases wow look at that
it's not 10.84 is still 10 bucks there
you go that's exactly how that works you
know we should do an inflation
inflation-adjusted price but we didn't
so there you go hey check it all out and
the ramsey cash giveaway grand prize of
three thousand dollars two days left no
purchase necessary for that you got to
be 18 or older to win
ramseysolutions.com
our question of the day comes from
blinds.com find out for yourself why
they are the number one online retailer
of custom window coverings with free
samples free shipping and new promos
that they run every month you'll save
even more use the promo code ramsey to
get the best deal today's question comes
from jeff in alaska he says i'm
currently on baby step 3 and my gross
income is 100k i have very little debt
other than the 125k left on my mortgage
i recently reviewed my union's insurance
plan and realize the disability coverage
is lower than it should be where in the
baby steps should i look at upping this
coverage or should i wait until step 7
to think about insurance
well you're right the baby steps don't
exactly cover insurance it's a part of
protecting what you're building along
the way
and dave when it comes to disability
insurance especially through your
employer what is the stance on where
that would fall
well i don't know what their coverage is
or where why he doesn't think it's
enough most of it is
you know 65 70
of your pay which is
equivalent to your take-home pay a lot
of times so it's probably not that far
off i don't know why he doesn't feel
like he's got adequate coverage through
the union i don't know what their deal
is um
but
buying supplemental disability is uh
depending on what you do for a living
you know it's not necessarily a good
deal so i might just approach this from
a different angle and say okay
since i don't have coverage it makes me
comfortable what i do need to offset
that is a big pile of money
and so i'd go about getting a big pile
of money more than i would worry about
buying supplemental disability insurance
but you're right no insurance is a baby
step
insurance of any kind is you need to
look at what you need
and appropriately get that you need
renters insurance if you're a renter
that covers your contents for fire and
fire and uh theft uh you obviously buy
home you need homeowners insurance you
buy an automobile you need automobile
insurance obviously health insurance
health insurance you need day one that
needs to be part of your budget all of
these things are part of it pretty much
all of them accept long-term care which
we recommend at 60 plus yep
life insurance you need you know once
you
have people that are counting on you for
your
independence you're
a spouse you've got kids
you know all these kinds of things so
yeah that that's what you're looking at
and
uh
and disability insurance for that matter
but you've got disability insurance you
just don't feel like it's adequately
covered so
let's say that it covers 50 of your
income of your take-home pay
and um you feel like that's not enough
because you you know you're accustomed
to 70 to 80 percent of your 50 of your
gross
uh and so well what you do would do is
offset that with a little bit higher
emergency fund and you know making sure
your other long-term investments your
retirement investments are cool
because if you've got a half million
dollars in you know in your 401k and
uh
you know you had a disability event and
you only got 50 of coverage
you're okay you'll be all right
financially anyway you'll be okay
that's what that's that's what we're
concerned about here so you offset that
risk with something else like money open
phones at triple eight eight two five
five two two five cj is in chattanooga
hi cj welcome to the ramsey show
hey how's it going guys better than we
deserve what's up
doing well my question is should we use
the potential student loan reimbursement
program to pay off our house i had uh
two or three student loans and that
would paid off in december 2020 it looks
like they may qualify potentially we'll
see how it all pans out but should i do
that
what's left on the mortgage
about thirty thousand dollars and how
much do you think you would get if you
got the forgiveness
uh probably about six or eight uh if
it's up to ten we'll have to see exactly
um
how
what the requirements are for
the reimbursement program
so this isn't going to clear the
mortgage you just are saying should we
apply it to the mortgage
well we also have about 20 000 in
savings that we could use to pay off the
house as well that's not including our
emergency fund oh awesome why aren't you
using the 20 000 today to pay down the
mortgage
uh i have my first child coming uh
september 23rd
just in case thank you thank you smart
yeah that makes sense
and uh we
i've been kind of tracking this to see
what's happening and it looks like the
student loan providers uh servicers are
not writing checks what they're doing is
reinstating the balance back to 10 000
and then saying all right good luck hope
the government clears that balance so
that's what's actually happening right
now as far as i can tell but he's
talking about ones he's already paid off
that's what they're saying they would
cut him a check
so that's what that's what i've been
seeing is if you've already paid it off
during the pause they're saying you can
get a refund according to the us
department of education but the refund
doesn't actually there's no checks being
cut their student loan services are
saying your balance is zero we're going
to put it back to 10
and then the government can forgive that
10.
hopefully wow well that doesn't make
sense i know but where did the money go
he wouldn't get a check that way
there would be i don't i don't know how
that's going to panic that's not logical
well that's the government i'm sorry i'm
sorry i just applied logic to the
federal that is a report from someone
who contacted their student loan service
excuse me lord forgive me jesus yeah
okay um
no
i that's not that's not right george
something's wrong i hope not well i mean
that's not because that way the uh the
student loan
lender would get the money
yeah the question is where is this money
how are people gonna get this money back
if they've already paid and we don't
know yet he's thinking he's getting a
check
um if he applies for it um
have you contacted your student loan
servicer
uh no yeah they don't know i mean nobody
knows it's all hearsay at this point
it's all it's all what might happen if
this crap goes through and if it's
declared legal instead of being an
executive order that which by the way
there's this thing called the
constitution that's going in the way and
um there's going to be lawsuits stopping
this and i don't know i i don't know i
i'm
i'm not worried about it i wouldn't
worry about it cj until it happens
uh because it might not uh
and
i've already caught enough crap on this
subject
nationally there i mean there's an
entire parade of dave ramsey haters out
there because i told people i think this
whole thing is absolutely horrendous and
bogus i'm happy for people who get their
loans forgiven but when you take
300 billion dollars 300 000 million
of other people's debt and put it on the
back of the taxpayers it's just immoral
as hell
and uh while you're continuing to make
the loans which is dishonest
if you keep making the loans it's
intellectually dishonest so i'm
i'm sitting here i'll just be very open
okay i'm sitting here trying to put cj's
shoes on and walk in them and say what
would i do if i was in his shoes and i'm
having trouble doing it
and that's not to slam you cj but i'm
having trouble doing it because i think
this whole thing is so bogus that to
actually receive the check from this
as like some kind of government benefit
after i've already paid off my loans it
just makes me want to puke
it makes me want to throw up i got a
little throw up in my mouth right now
and so it's just um
yeah it just makes my blood boil i'd
continue on with the babies there's so
much wrong with it and um
there's a part of me cj that says you
already paid off your loan you ought to
just keep moving with your life dude
there's a part of me that says that
inside i understand the other side of it
i get it intellectually i'm just being a
bit emotional
[Music]
if you're looking for ways to update
your home without blowing the budget
i've got it for years i've been telling
you about our friends at blinds.com
blinds.com makes it simple to shop top
quality blinds shades and interior
shutters from home with easy online
ordering and free shipping with
blinds.com there's no need to renovate
your entire home just change out what's
on your windows with upscale choices
like faux wood blinds cellular and
roller shades or even outdoor shades
plus blinds.com guarantees the perfect
fit whether you do it yourself or you
have them measure and install everything
for you shop their latest looks and see
how much you can save at blinds.com
today the easy and affordable way to
make your home more beautiful is
blinds.com
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
george campbell ramsey personality is my
co-host in the lobby of ramsey solutions
on the debt free stage lena is with us
hi lena how are you hi dave welcome
where do you live i live in frederick
maryland oh welcome to nashville good to
have you here and so how much debt have
you paid off
53
500. all right and how long did this
take you 28 months good for you and your
range of income during that time um i
started with 76 000 and by the end of
last year it was around
87 000. good for you what do you do for
a living so i currently work in
management for southwest airlines and
also part of this journey has been
picking up as many side gigs as i have
been able to go in order to complete
this journey cool we do a lot of stuff
with southwest it's a good company yeah
so very very cool very proud what are
your uh what are your side gigs that you
did what's the best one that made you
the most money well the one that helped
me the most was a brand marketer so i
helped
several
brands including wellness products and
spirits and wines
promote their beverages and
yeah
and uh personal training i took up a
personal training gig um as well because
it's very exciting to help people
improve their lives wow very cool good
for you what kind of debt was the 54 000
so i had about thirty seven thousand
dollars of uh student loan and eight
thousand dollars of uh credit card
and um another eight thousand dollar
remaining on my bmw card ah of course
okay very cool so what happened to you
28 months ago that started this whole
following the ramsey way thing well um i
had a friend at work at southwest that
a long time ago she had posted something
about dave ramsey and your total money
makeover
that
impacted me in some way but i honestly i
don't think that when i saw that post i
was ready to make those changes it
wasn't until
a few years later that i met my fiance
johnny that
he really
lives by what you preach he talks about
um dave ramsey this they ramsay that the
baby steps and he watches your show
daily and it inspired me to learn more
and
i talked to him about my goals and the
things that i wanted to accomplish um i
moved from venezuela when i was um
really young i was um so long story
short i was born here moved to venezuela
when i was seven and came back at the
age of 19 ready for college so that was
like the beginning of my journey with
that
i didn't know what i was doing so i
signed up for a loan that i obviously
couldn't pay off because i didn't have
the right job to pay for it
and then everything trickled from there
so
johnny knew about my story and he wanted
to help so he bought me the book and um
through the pandemic i just felt like it
was the perfect time to really focus on
what you really wanted because there was
nothing else to be worried about it and
while everybody else was
um
very few distractions yes very few
distractions um i i just use this time
to kind of like hit the reset button and
really focus
and not let anything get on the way
that's awesome he sounds like a keeper
and it sounds like you're keeping him
around so that's great you guys have a
wedding date yes march 25th all right
that is awesome and you're you're
starting to debt free yeah i assume he's
debt-free as well he's been following
this stuff that's fantastic absolutely
so what was the hardest part for you was
there a moment where you're like oh my
gosh this is brutal uh yeah i i'm not
gonna lie to you it's not easy it's uh
it's almost it felt like um an identity
crisis because you have like this
lifestyle and you have this cool things
that you like to do and you like to like
i work in the airline industry and i was
a flight attendant for a very long time
so it becomes normal
to travel and do cool things with your
friends and all that but in reality you
can't really afford that travel because
it's not only the airfare you now have
to pay to stay there
and do all the other cool things that
you want to do when you're traveling so
it was just more of like that adjustment
of that reality check of like hey i
can't really do these things that i
think are okay of doing like i really
have to
change my ways and
not really worry at all about what other
people think because the thing is
it's that's i think that's the hardest
part you just just have to feel like you
have to explain to people why you're
doing the things that you're doing and
break free from that i think for me that
was the hardest part and um
obviously we get into this situation
because you're not disciplined so
getting the discipline to just stick to
what you're doing and plan and
strategize how you're gonna do it like
for me i knew that um with my salary
alone i wasn't gonna be able to make
that happen so
how much more do i need every month in
order to complete those payments i
actually wanted to pay it off in 24
months but that was a little hard it
took me a little bit longer than 24 but
close enough
so what do you tell people the absolute
key to getting out of that is
well the key would be to
to know that it's going to be really
hard that you are going to encounter a
lot of bumps along the road and that
you just have to be
true to yourself
true to your goal and think and honestly
like revamp your value system
um you just have to change your values
like the things that were important to
you before they can continue to be
important because then you're really not
going to make it
and yeah and just go from there i think
if you remind yourself every morning
what you are like what your goal is
and
just focus focus like write things down
i love to write things down
in a journal or and then i have a a
board
in my bedroom that um i write the things
that i need to remind myself for that
week cool we're proud of you hero well
done thank you very very well done i
know he's proud of you sitting over
cheering you on life is good and proud
of him too because he helped you this is
great it's great hand-off
good good work we've got a copy of baby
steps millionaires for you that's the
next chapter in your story for sure to
go on and become millionaires as a newly
married couple starting next march
and financial peace university a
one-year membership to that as well and
if you guys haven't been through that
you can go through it together as a
premarital thing it's a really good
pre-marriage class
and as a part of your overall
pre-marriage anyway work uh and a copy
of total money makeover which you've
already got that means you can give this
one away so that's perfect so
good stuff very very very well done i'm
so proud of you good good work
all right lena from fred frederick
maryland 54 000 paid off in 28 months
making 76 to 87. count it down let's
hear a debt free scream
um that's
[Applause]
[Music]
very well done i love that she upgraded
her values she used to value other
people's opinion of her and now she
values freedom and not owing anyone
anything that's good that's a worthy
upgrade in values right there good
insight very good insight yeah there is
something that happens
in transformation that has to occur
for you you know you can't keep doing
the same thing over and over and expect
a different result that's the definition
of insanity so this transformation idea
is that
um it is more than simply a
a mathematical activity to get out of
debt the heart has to change
and that's what happened you got to
start caring about different things and
it's a superpower to not care what
people think in america today that is
one of the keys to building wealth if
you have that and common sense oh my
you're a bonafide superhero and a
unicorn at that yeah that's really cool
but that's exactly what we need in
america today
yeah people of character with common
sense who don't care what other people
think there you go that's a magical
formula yeah
and um
i i will share that that you can go too
far with not caring what other people
think and i want you to shower and have
good hygiene i mean because i just truly
don't care and i and i really need to
care a little bit it's worked for you so
far i know but i need to care a little
bit it's kind of unkind at some point
and it's just uh it's like i just truly
don't give a rip and it's it's a bit of
a problem i need to be a little nicer
that's what makes you dave that's why we
love you yeah right yeah that's it
that's that's exactly what it was that's
what that's the whole definition of dave
that's it it's that simple thanks george
i'm here to make you feel good
good job lina good work good work good
work well done awesome this is the
ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
george campbell ramsey personality is my
co-host today thank you for joining us
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five
two two five rick is with us rick is in
austin texas hi rick how are you
hi dave and george i'm doing great how
are you guys better than we deserve sir
what's up
well i just wanted to call and say thank
you because it makes a huge difference
when you purchase a vehicle in cash
versus all the other ways i've done it
over the years so thank you dave well
you're welcome so you bought a car in
cash
uh yes sir i did what'd you buy we had a
trade in my wife and i it was a subaru
ascent
2022. so a brand new one we made sure we
met the guidelines that you usually lay
out for that but uh we went in we
purchased a car and spent less time than
i've ever spent buying a car in my
entire life which was fantastic wow so
you guys baby steps millionaires
yes sir oh my goodness that's fantastic
way to go rick how long have you been
doing this uh this journey following our
stuff
uh my wife and i have been married for
10 years i've been on the program
probably for about 15. that's awesome
living it out that's a perfect timing
that's it fits the guy i mean if it's
the standard case study of the
millionaires the baby steps millionaires
that we wrote about in baby steps
millionaires the book because it shows
people exactly how rick did what he did
and people like him so way to go rick
that's awesome man love hearing that
congratulations we're proud of you good
work
spencer's with us in columbia south
carolina hi spencer how are you
good hey dave how george how are you
guys doing better than we deserve what's
up
so uh my wife and i we just had our
first baby about a week and a half ago
oh congratulations what'd you have
thank you it's a girl
so
we're trying to get set up
to start putting money away to save for
college and just trying to think through
the best way to do that so
i'm familiar with 529 plans but
it seems like there's a lot of different
options out there for 529 and then i
just wasn't sure if there was any other
type of account um that might be a
better alternative
now 529 is about the best thing there is
but you're right there is a bunch of
options the only option you want is the
kind where you select the type of mutual
funds that go in it each individual fund
and it does not change unless you change
it it's not on autopilot of any kind
gotcha okay yeah and if you got that one
of our smartvestor pros they can help
you line those things up and
you know generally i just dump it into a
simple growth stock mutual fund but what
you don't want to get into is one of
these things where they move the funds
around as the kid gets older without
uh it's kind of an autopilot thing it's
hypothetically lower risk but it ends up
being a stupid move kind of like a
target date fund exactly so you don't
want that but there's a lot of
state-specific ones and you can choose
one from a lot of states so your
smartvestor pro can help you choose the
best one for what you're trying to do
which is awesome
okay and so the 529 is going to be
better than just like standard mutual
funds i mean i guess i was thinking if
she doesn't end up going to college is
that money going to be tied up you know
versus just putting it in typical
mutual funds well anything any type of
furthering her education i mean if she
goes to tech school you can use it and
listen you don't need to i i'm just
going to be grandpa for a second train
your child to be a continuous learner
yeah post post high school doing zero
education of any kind
is not a good idea
you are going to be you're going to be
at a huge disadvantage in the
marketplace so by god learn something
somewhere if you're not doing if you
know if you're not doing higher
education that's fine
so quote college but there needs to be
some kind of a track
that involves education because um you
know
like for instance i'll tell you if we're
interviewing someone to work at ramsey
for a leadership role and we say hey
what books have you read recently and
they say i haven't interview's over
i don't need people in here who aren't
learning and growing and getting better
i read like crazy because i i'm an idiot
on some things i don't know what's going
on i have to read a book about it right
and so uh you know i've learned
more post education
from books and uh classes and so forth
than i did when i was in education yeah
or when i was going through getting a
four-year degree so
you don't want to just get
the school of hard knocks because the
knocks are harder
if you if you don't know where to dodge
and the other option for you is the esa
the education savings account those are
the only two i'd recommend for college
saving and i would rather have too much
money for college than not enough you
can always change the beneficiary on
that and if she gets a scholarship you
can withdraw from the account for that
amount there's a lot of options here so
i would just go ahead and save and we
don't know what the cost of college is
going to do probably skyrocket now with
this forgiveness and everything they're
doing with income-based repayment so
yeah i'd go ahead and start saving now
yeah there's a lot thanks thanks for the
call man you're right that's a an
opinion piece i saw the other day um uh
actually delony found itself oh yeah i
read that one uh that's my involvement i
think the the forgiveness is going to
cause a further increase intuition yeah
because part of the forgiveness program
that's proposed if it comes through
if it actually happens is that
the rest of the balance can be done
as a percentage of your income for the
rest of your life and so just pay them
for the rest of your life
at five or ten percent of your income
isn't that number and crud yes that's
true because then colleges are going we
can charge four hundred thousand you
know why why are if you're so stupid
that you did that how did you get out of
college
i mean if you're if you're so dumb you
sign up for that program
how'd you get out of school in the first
place
i don't the whole thing baffles me it
just baffles me the stupidity on parade
the island of misfit toys doing a dance
it's unbelievable all right let's see
here
hey
luke is in virginia hey luke what's up
hey dave thanks for taking my call sure
how can i help um so
i learned financial peace in high school
as a result i have no student loan debt
i have no credit card debt the only
thing i owe any man is i was in a
motorcycle accident a couple years ago
and so i have a few thousand dollars
maybe three thousand dollars in medical
debt i just settled with the insurance
company
for nine hundred thousand dollars
because it almost took my leg they told
me if a car was going to hit me it
should be this one
uh because it was insured by a major
corporation and it was a business car
and so my question to you is as somebody
with no debt and who is on uh i believe
baby step five a point of saving money
for uh
kids for college and i don't have kids
yet i'm not married yet
should i invest the 900 000
in mutual funds or given the volatility
of the potential recession for the
recession we're in right now should i
consider other investment options with
that 900 000
good lord how you doing
i i have a metal rod in my leg
and
it'll be there for the rest of my life
but i am i have a personal goal of being
able to run a 5k
and uh i got to three miles last night
so i'm not going to sit around and mope
about it i'm gonna do everything i
possibly can to to make a bad situation
as good as i can man
900 grand how old are you
26. wow oh my goodness and do you own a
home
no i rent okay all right
uh what do you do for a living no what
do you make what do you make what's your
income
i make 110 000 a year and then i have a
small business on the side that brings
in about 20 000 so around 130 000 a year
and i take it you're single
yes but i plan to be married within the
next year um
be purchasing a ring as part of the
part of the settlement yeah all right um
i'm going to rattle this off real fast
are you ready
yeah
okay um you are a candidate for losing
all of this money because you've never
handled the money of this type before
yep so i want you to not number one
don't put money in anything you don't
understand
if that means you just put it in a
savings account forget it that's fine
high yield savings account put it in
three different banks forget it that's
fine okay number two
um
were you dating her before all this
happened
uh no get a prenup
okay number three you need to put a
group of people in your corner that
become your board of directors to help
advise you
insurance
number one
a good insurance broker that can help
you with insurance number two you need a
good investment professional get a smart
investor pro
in your corner number three you need a
good real estate agent in your corner
because you probably need to buy a house
that she helps you pick
because she's gonna be living there and
if you buy the house without her you're
gonna buy the wrong one
so you need to get a good real estate
agent um
and have yourself a board of directors a
board of advisors that teach you
all these different components of
handling that amount of money well and
then you'll make good slow
careful wise decisions
there you go this is the ramsey show
dave here you can find all of our shows
with the ramsey network app on your
smartphone it's the only place to listen
to the entire back catalog of episodes
download the ramsey network app in your
favorite app store today
[Music]
bye
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions it's the ramsey show where
debt is dumb cash is king and the paid
off home mortgage has taken the place of
the bmw as the status symbol of choice
we help people build wealth do work that
they love and create actual amazing
relationships george campbell ramsey
personality
host of the entree leadership podcast is
my co-host today
this hour is an entree leadership theme
hour which means we are going to talk
about business
leadership and particularly small
business if you want to talk about it
entree leadership is a book that i did
several years ago it was our playbook
and still is our playbook for how we run
this business it's our it's got all our
super bowl plays in it how we won the
super bowl how we've grown this from a
card table in my living room to
today about 1200 team members and a
major national brand
the word entree leadership is one we
made up it's a combination of
entrepreneurship and leadership who came
up with that that's clever
was that you underhand pitch yeah look
at you i'm just i have no idea
truthfully where you really don't i
don't know the story
oh my gosh that's amazing well
when i was sitting down to uh think
about we were i originally taught the
material to our team people that wanted
to run up you know wanted to grow inside
of our business i was trying to grow our
leadership development trying to grow
leaders inside the business and um
i didn't want a leadership class
because
i was in management class in college
taught by a tenured professor who had
never made payroll and when i hear the
word leadership sometimes i have uh i
get a little twitch
because i kind of remember management
class takes you back but real leadership
i don't have an issue with but it just
kind of reminded me of that and so i
didn't want to just say this is our
leadership handbook you know i didn't
want to do that and i didn't really want
just entrepreneurs because we
entrepreneurs are all a little bit add
and every little shiny thing we're like
a bass we go after everything that's
shiny it's like squirrel right i mean
you know you get that uh thing and so i
didn't because managing a whole building
full of those people would be like
trying to nail jello to a tree so i had
no desire to do that but i did want the
energy of the entrepreneur and the
sophistication of the leader the servant
attitude of the leader so we combined
them entree leadership entrepreneurship
and leadership entree leadership that's
where it comes from so open phones if
you want to talk about business this
hour this is your time
george is here he has interviewed a
bazillion business
experts on the podcast and so can i jump
in and help as well on this the phone
number here triple eight eight two five
five two two
five joe is in charlotte to start us off
this hour hey joe welcome to the ramsey
show
hey dave thanks for having me sure
what's up
oh not a whole lot i just want to start
out by saying you know such an honor to
be on on air with you
you've
helped me guide my life through fbu and
entree leadership from the very
beginning so cool just super grateful
for that
thank you um i searched one to start out
with
so i have about 10
team members in my company we're in
diesel truck and trailer repair out of
the charlotte north
north carolina area
we're in the pathfinder stage i'm
getting ready to roll out our mission
vision and core values to the team good
so my question is you know how do i go
about doing that to create the most
buy-in from everybody
and so that way just get it kicked off
from the very beginning in the most
efficient way yeah
well i mean
you can't instill core values as a boss
you have to do it as a leader
bosses push and leaders pull
and so pull means persuasion
instead of wagging your finger
right
and and so you know here's our core
values this is who we are
and this is how i teach it at ramsey the
ramsey team will tell you i say this all
the time if you want to be a we
this is who we are
if you're not this you're not a we
meaning get your butt out right that's
what we're saying this is who we are
and so this you know we're french we we
right this is us and so this is us and
so like you know what is one of your
core values as an example joe
um dignity in our work okay
and that's not a um
aspirational meaning it's not what you
wish
it is instead actually who you are
okay
right i mean sometimes people put
sometimes corporate america in
particular which is really bad about
worried about optics and their virtue
signaling and all this other crap that
they do instead of actually getting
their work done
but corporate america is real bad about
here's our core value which means that's
what they wish they were that's
aspirational we aspire to be that we
hope to be that
and our core values at ramsey we didn't
do that we wrote down who we are
and then anybody that's not that is not
a we
you know and so dignity in our work and
so you know and you said you guys are
what diesel mechanics is that what you
said
yes sir okay and so
if you look down
on diesel mechanics
as beneath you
and you don't see that as work that
matters you don't see that as a work
that has dignity then you're not a we
because i own this place and i see this
as a calling i see it as a great service
that we provide to some of the hardest
working americans people on the other
side of a diesel are generally some of
the hardest working people you're going
to run into right
yes sir and keeping them on the road and
keeping them in the field and keeping
them operating is is is is a mission
with dignity
and if you can't really get excited
about that you you know i probably
messed up when i brought you in here and
i'm so sorry i owe you an apology
because this is who we are i believe
this has dignity i believe this is work
that matters because we're keeping some
of the hardest working most productive
people on the planet
engaged in because we keep their stuff
running
and that if you can't get dignity out of
that man
i mean you know you don't you don't love
hard-working people
and instead you just think you're some
kind of grease monkey i don't need you
in here man
and that's how that's how i would do it
from the stage at ramsey wouldn't i
george joe i wish dave could just go
over there and do it for you but uh
you're the leader buddy
and i know you're like well i'm not the
mo you gotta care and so you can't just
read this off a slide like you're just
communicating some information you have
to show your passion and know that this
is just level setting you're setting a
foundation this is not the first and
last time they're going to hear these
core values you have to do we talk about
it all the time we do them a couple
times a month in staff meeting we're
doing one of one of them again
and and people go well you know i've
been here 20 years i've heard you do
that a whole bunch of times yep you're
going to hear it again too
because we talk about it all the time
we talk about it all the time if you
don't repeat it it's not going to happen
it's you don't get to make one
announcement joe and this is over this
is just the first of 8 000 announcements
you're going to make regarding this and
then you're going to live it out day in
and day out and you're going to let the
culture build with the team as they live
it out that's how this stuff sticks
yes sir does that make sense
yeah and
so i i think the i think and you can
explain to them this is not who we wish
we were this is who i am
and in a small business
you know who you are is the dna of the
place
so this is our values
and uh you know i think that what you
guys do
and what we do at this company is is
important i think it's work that matters
i think it has great dignity
and so if you can't get on board with
that
then you know you're not gonna it's not
gonna work out here for you
and you don't have to threaten them with
that on the first day you announce it
but you're just gonna start to describe
this is who we are this is who we are
this is who we are and don't be shocked
if one or two of the ten someday decides
that they're not that
and you know and as a country friend of
mine says you ain't gonna fit in around
here boy this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
george campbell ramsey personality host
of the entree leadership podcast is my
co-host today we're taking calls this
hour on entre leadership business
questions small business questions
leadership questions thank you for
joining us america the phone number is
triple eight eight two five five two two
five cindy is in boston hi cindy welcome
to the ramsey show
hi dave thank you thank you how can i
help
okay so
my question is how do i hire when p
everyone applying is looking for wages
much higher than ever before and out of
our comfort zone also looking for
benefits that we've never accommodated
before
including longer vacations sick time
retirement etc yeah
small business has never been able to
compete with corporate america on
benefits packages
um and so like when we had 30 employees
uh we said our benefit package consisted
of your checks going to clear
we we didn't have back in those days we
didn't have health insurance
we didn't have squat but what we did
have was you actually were going to be
eating lunch with the ceo every day
because there wasn't that many of us
right we all fit at one table and what
we did have was you're going to be
treated with dignity and you're going to
be treated like family
and you're going to have a whole
different kind of environment than
working in stupid corporate america
that's lost its soul
and so you don't you you from an
employee's standpoint you're in a much
better environment without all the crazy
optic virtue signaling garbage in
corporate america if you want to be in
that world head on over there baby i
don't want nothing to do with those
people
and uh and if you want to work for them
you're actually not the kind of people
we want anyway so
we brand differentiated by the quality
of the culture the quality of the
environment not by the benefits package
and as a matter of fact today with 1200
team members we don't try to compete
with huge companies
uh
you know that
uh whatever
policy that they have i don't even get
into it we're not going to do it we're
just going to be us and if you don't
work here you're working here because
the work matters because it's big deal
to be working on something that changes
people's lives and we're gonna pay
reasonably we're gonna pay competitively
but uh if you want eight weeks of
vacation you know we're not about how
much vacation you have we're about how
much work you do
uh including me by the way hello i work
and so you know uh uh
but but if you want if that if that if
they come in and
right off the bat the thing they're
concerned about the benefits package you
won't hire them anyway because they're
there for what they can get rather than
what they can add
and so
it's always a problem now what we do
have that we're facing and that is a
legitimate thing is the wage issue
the cost
to hire somebody has gone up
dramatically especially in
uh certain uh
certain disciplines
okay developers for instance uh software
engineers
way up
in just uh 24 months
just way up
and well i'm even just talking about the
retail
so in a retail environment yeah you're
competing with people that want to pay
20 and 30 bucks to work at target
right yeah right i mean
and that that's so what we're having to
do and what you're going to have to do
there is uh we're going to we're having
to look and go um
we can't afford it
so you said comfort zone it's not in
your comfort zone does that mean you're
not really roi on the payroll
the i'm roi
currently on the payroll but to add like
one more person would just be yeah
yeah yeah and so i'd love to i'll give
you an example if the developers if if a
senior developer is 300 000 a year
writing code and they used to be 200 000
a year if i could make money with the
code they wrote at 200 and i can't at
300 it means i'm not hiring them
right they price themselves out of the
market
and they have to work somewhere else
and we're ex we're actually having that
conversation in the last six months here
that exact conversation right there so i
mean it might not be numbers that big
with someone working retail but if you
can make it work at uh 15 an hour but
everybody else is paying 25
and when you hire them at 25 you
actually lose money on the activity that
they are engaged in
then uh
you know the idea in business is if
you're going to take on payroll you make
more than it costs you
otherwise you go out of business right
absolutely yeah and so you just have to
look up and go i can't i
not able to hire anybody to do that
because i can't pay that
and so one of two things is going to
happen then wages are going to adjust on
that type of position or you're going to
figure out a way to get a return on
investment on that that that person
working is going to make you more than
they cost you
but they have to make you more than they
cost you or by definition you're heading
out of business
it's frustrating as crud right now what
kind of retailer are you
jewelry jewelry interesting yeah
yeah we do custom design and
bridal mostly
and a lot of a lot of in-house work so
okay are you trying to hire a jeweler or
somebody work the front counter
oh both would be great yeah you know but
trying to find anybody too that's
qualified is really difficult as well
that knows that's another that's another
topic that doesn't think carrots are on
salad yeah
right
yeah so it's interesting it's been very
difficult and essentially since we shut
down and then everybody comes out
everybody lost their job or everybody
like is looking for a new job because
they can
and then they're coming out just looking
for
a lot more like a third more 50 more
than
what we were paying before what is the
hourly you're trying to fill rate
25 you're offering 25
yeah between 20 and 25 depending on and
what is that work that's to work the
front counter and they need to know
something about diamonds
they need to know something about
diamonds yeah and um
you used to pay how much
18. okay and
and so they're asking for 35.
no they're asking for more they're
looking for salary they're looking for
um extra you know vacation time on top
of that so it's like so i'm paying you
to not be here
when
i don't have anybody to cover for you
except for me
and you know yeah
if someone is in that spirit i'm not
interested in having them on my team
right
but there's more and more of them coming
through the door i know i know
i got i mean i got the same thing
and you know like we used to say around
here that uh we've i got a ton of
millennials on the team and a ton of gen
z's on the team
and people just talk about how bad a
worker they are and they're all
self-centered and they're all arrogant
and all that stuff they're all
snowflakes they're not
they're not there's a percentage of them
are participation trophy idiots
and there's a percentage of them they'll
charge the gates of hell with a water
pistol they're the most crusade-driven
wonderful team members i've ever had
but you've got to get the ones that
actually you know that like weren't
raised by by uh uh nintendo and instead
actually had parents
in other words they have they have a
work ethic they have value system
you know instead of sitting around going
the whole access of the world runs
through the top of your pointed little
head
and because it doesn't and so what
you're running into is the frustration
of the percentage of that population
that is self-centered entitled and
arrogant and you don't want them on your
team for any amount of money
if you could get them at sixteen dollars
if you could get them at fourteen
dollars you wouldn't want them
because they're there for what they can
get rather than what they can add
and it's frustrating as crud
hiring and running a team
managing culture in the team is one of
the hardest business problems i've ever
tried to solve and it's a constant
day in and day out battle
to go oh you can't work here anymore
look at the way look look at you you
just misbehaved that's unbelievable
or nope we're not even going to have
another conversation about it at this
interview it's over
and you just end it i mean it's very
hard in the georgetown we fight it we
fight it here yeah and you're there's
always the worry they're gonna leave for
a nickel more because if they came in
the door with their demands they're
gonna go to the next place as soon as
they can find an extra nickel there and
that's that's one of the problems you
got to find people who care and you
might need to give them room to grow
we've had some people leave because they
wanted to work from home and we don't
work from home
and so we said you know what that was a
good move
you should leave self-selected because
we don't work from home
because you know we don't not work from
home or whatever it was elon said right
that's the deal yeah no thank you we're
not doing that we actually believe that
it's not good that man be alone
it's good that men be next to men and
you know talking to each other and
having brainstorming sessions and
creative that happens in person
and these companies are finding out that
work from home is killing their
productivity this is the ramsey show
[Music]
so
[Music]
george campbell ramsey personality host
of the entree leadership podcast is my
co-host today
this hour is an entree leadership
theme hour we're talking with business
owners business leaders about business
questions leadership
questions and like our callers today if
you're a business owner you've got
questions about the tactical how to's of
running a company uh we run one every
day here
uh so we are not uh theoretical people
in some classroom somewhere we're actual
practitioners and we put together a
thing called the entree leadership
master series and we will show you the
tactical how to's of business
it is a serious
hard long
week
and uh the conference is a crash course
and all the tactical lessons that we've
learned in 30 years of doing the
business you will leave tired
uh overwhelmed
uh totally informed we've had people say
stuff like i learned more in this five
days than i did getting my mba
and uh we're hosting the master series
in nashville our own hometown
here on the 25th through the 29th of
september about a month away
and uh less than a month away we have
like 15 or 20 seats left
something like that it is almost sold
out
but we thought since we're doing an
entree leadership theme hour we give you
a chance to come if you want to come you
got a month to get ready and you got
about a day to buy your ticket because
they're going to be gone so if you're
interested in coming to entre leadership
enjoying nashville and learning more
than you have ever learned in a
leadership course because boy we pour it
on i'm teaching most of the lessons this
year
so uh personally so it's a lot of fun i
love being with small business people
love being with business people it's my
favorite thing i think business small
business is the backbone of the american
economy and i've got statistics to prove
it so go to ramseysolutions.com
master series to reserve your seats as
the uh podcast uh host are you doing
something there this year i will be in
attendance uh i'll make a cameo at some
of the events there a cameo yeah that's
what they call it these days is it okay
but these are these are star you get
cameos i am inspired by just meeting
these business owners they're incredible
and one of the things that is
fascinating is one of the best parts of
the event is them meeting each other
because business is lonely yeah as a
business owner and so to talk to someone
else who may be in your field maybe
across the country who knows it just
gives
fuel to your soul to keep fighting you
know we've been doing these over a
decade and
almost two decades and uh
we have people that come to these events
every year and they've been friends for
a long time and they met at this event
but they're running businesses across
the country sometimes the same industry
sometimes not but they just strike up a
cord because there's something about
small business people that are cut from
the same cloth so if you want to come
entree leadership master series
september
25th through the 29th go to
ramseysolutions.com
master series and you can reserve a seat
ramsey solutions dot com
slash master series sabrina is in new
hampshire hey sabrina welcome to the
ramsay show what's up hi dave and george
thank you for taking my call today sure
how can we help all right so my husband
and i own a small business a heavy
equipment repair shop
the business is debt free and personally
we're in baby step seven so my question
is how much do we pay ourselves
and what do we do with the rest of our
profits
do you have suggested budgeting
guidelines for giving marketing retained
earnings and investing
uh we're doing well and have great
profit margins so we just really don't
know what to do with our money now which
is a good problem to have oh it's
wonderful congratulations very well done
very well done well what we do is we set
a percentage for different categories
inside the business that we're going to
use
like you said marketing is an example
and um and then we adjust it
if it ends up being too much we adjust
it down
uh
you know one of our categories that we
spend a ton of money on our team on hr
and so events that we do for our team
gifts that we do for our team
team members that are in crisis and we
come alongside them
all of that is as a percentage of budget
and sometimes it run you covering the
christmas party and by the time we come
up on the christmas party at the end of
the year sometimes that percentage
wasn't enough and we have to beef it up
sometimes it wasn't more than enough and
we've got too much going in and we end
up doing something else with it but um
we're not obligated by law to spend any
of that so it's just something we made
up right same thing with your marketing
and so you say all right we're going to
spend x percentage and with that we
still make a fine profit
and but if you end up saying gosh we
don't really need to spend that much to
get the business in the door we could
spend less than you dial it down a
couple points right
and then as far as the profits go it's
all yours just take it home what's the
problem i mean set aside set aside we do
set a percentage that has not changed in
years
uh for growing retained earnings
and so if you've got cash stacked inside
the business that equals half your half
a year of operating
you probably got enough cash in the
business okay and you could just start
you know you could reduce that amount
then but i would put a percentage
of my profits into
uh the retained earnings which is for
future growth it's for
buying things equipment it's for
uh
emergencies it's the business emergency
fund it's all of those things and just
put a percentage of your profits towards
that and then take the rest of it home
that's what it's for you run a business
so you make a profit and take it home
there's no obligation to leave it
sitting down there
okay that was that was my concern was i
didn't know if it's safer to stuff it
all away or if we can enjoy some
it's just
well i mean you don't want to be down
there with no cash right but you also
don't need i mean
uh if you have a five million dollar
your business you don't need 20 million
dollars sitting down there in cash
either
you know
okay do you feel like you're not paying
yourselves enough right now
we are
gross household income is 110 000 right
now so i feel like we make plenty
especially now that we don't have a
mortgage payment
yeah but that's just the salary you're
taking out that's not your profits
correct
your profits are all taxable whether you
leave them down there or not
because subs and llc are both passed
through and so all your profits are
taxable every year whether you leave it
at the office or whether you take it
home you're already paying taxes on the
profits you might as well just take them
home and enjoy them if the business has
got the cash that it needs for retained
earnings and for marketing and for doing
the operation of the business
you know and then the rest of it i take
home
in my case
and uh
you know now i
am investing in uh our our building
complexes out of my personal income
uh around this campus here and so take
it home and and it ends up staying on
the property but not inside of the
ramsey solutions business it moves over
into family stuff we're building these
buildings and that so that that's the
difference there so but yeah good stuff
good stuff jeff is with us jeff is in
knoxville hi jeff what's your business
question for today
okay kind of taking on what she had but
um we have extra cash as well and i'm
just wondering if you had a
a you know income
to profit ratio of you know like uh what
what how much when should we take that
cash out and invest it in something you
know um that's kind of what we're trying
to figure out that
that that ratio
well i mean as far as retained earnings
go and very few businesses need more
than six months of operating capital
got you um now it now in addition to
that if you see some big purchase in the
future
you know you need to buy a half million
dollar piece of equipment then you would
tack on something to go do that with
right
but your retained earnings uh cover cash
flow fluctuations since you're not
borrowing money with a line of credit
your retained earnings cover emergencies
um
you know your retained earnings cover
some some purchases of items but if
you've got a something that is a major
thing you probably want to budget for
that over a period of time
but uh there's not a set margin rate i
mean i've got like 14 different profit
centers inside the business and
publishing operates on different margins
than live events do
and so you know whatever kind of
business you're in is going to have
different margins
right right yeah we basically have you
know three divisions um in our business
you know yeah but the industry that
you're in
may have a a fairly standard margin
for those three things that you can look
at but you know there's not one that all
small business should have x percent of
margin no
because especially people dealing with
hard goods like for instance publishing
the margins are smaller
if you're dealing with digital your
margins go through the roof because your
cost of goods sold as air
you know it's it's just the production
of the item so these are good problems
to have running your business debt-free
and having too much money these are
great products i love these business
owners horrible well done horrible
situation here you have too much money
don't know what to do is send it to
georgia's bahamas i'll send you my venmo
that's it
[Music]
open phones this hour triple eight eight
two five five two two five
[Music]
[Music]
our scripture of the day proverbs 24 16
for the righteous falls seven times
and rises again but the wicked stumble
in times of calamity
winston churchill said success is
walking from failure to failure with no
loss
of enthusiasm
there it is it's an entree leadership
theme hours we talk small business
business and leadership this hour george
campbell ramsey personality host of the
entree leadership podcast is my co-host
if you want to come to our ontario
leadership master series the end of
september there's a handful of tickets
left go to ramsey ramseysolutions.com
events and you can find out everything
that's going on there ramsay
solutions.com oh slash master series
i'll put you right on the page actually
but if you hit events you can always
find out all of our events that are
going on and we did announce earlier
today
that the
san antonio event for building wealth is
sold out in september the phoenix event
the second one we launched is within a
handful of seats being sold out we'll
probably announce it tomorrow as a sell
out so if you want to go to those entree
leadership just has a handful of seats
for this summit left if you want to come
so we'd love to have you at all of these
things but don't dilly dally around get
yourself in there and get you a ticket
all right toby is with us toby is in
bowling green kentucky hi toby how are
you
doing well mr ramsey how about yourself
sir better than we deserve brother how
can we help
yes sir so we uh have grown our company
uh in a very good fashion and we are
moving more towards owning the
infrastructure through the family or the
family trust and leasing back to the the
organization as far as the
infrastructure
with some of the tax benefits there and
what i'm looking for some advice on is
how to protect the family more
when they own the infrastructure and
it'll be several dollars worth in the in
the
several million one plant could be a
couple million one could be two or three
million so we're talking about some
significant dollars there okay so the
plant that's worth a couple million
dollars is in a trust
that the family is a beneficiary has a
beneficial interest on the trust
and you're leasing it back to the
company
yes sir that's correct
what do you need protection from
uh well i'll give you a small example uh
and i'm just looking for input on this
we have several gasoline convenience
stores i had a lady pull up got this on
camera got fuel
uh was a drop top mercedes took off with
the gas pump in her car hose whipped
around poured fuel into her car and
naturally
got an ambulance chaser sued us over it
started out about 15 grand that's when i
found out the the good balancing act
with the insurance company and as the
first time we had to settle for like
five thousand dollars over something
that was clearly not our fault so when i
look at us owning infrastructure
personally through the families and
leasing back to the companies my concern
is this say somebody drives up runs in
your front wall
it could be their fault if an ambulance
chase or lawyer type then represents
that person naturally they could sue the
company for a settlement but if they do
enough digging they're going to find out
that the family owns it leases back to
the company
the family doesn't own it
trust owns it
the trust owns it correct they can sue
the trucks
yeah
okay so the building i'm sitting in is
owned by my family trust and it's leased
to my company
all of which by the way i control but
that doesn't mean you have access to it
if you run a bill run a truck through
the front of it you can only sue the
trust
you can sue the company that's operating
you can see both of them
uh but you know you're not getting me
personally because i'm not the owner
so when you guys do that you guys didn't
get like a one recommended
recommendation that happens so like
let's say one physical plant the company
has general liability insurance for five
months of course you ought to have that
yep
you need that that doesn't but if
there's if the lawsuit's for 50 million
they won't help
correct so what the only thing you can
do is keep the ass is uh what i've done
and a lot of folks doing from a risk
management scenario is you spread the
assets into different ownership groups
and so like i would not have one trust
on all six gas stations i'd have a
different trust for each gas station
okay it's a pain in the butt because you
gotta you got five tax returns to file
you got five sets of corporate crap with
the state you got five sets of
everything but then if they take one of
the gas stations away from you in a
lawsuit because they beat that deal on
that trust you hand them the keys to it
and you close it down and you got the
other four
that makes sense i just visited an oil
company out west and they own a whole
block they're a lot larger than us and
they have i don't put more than i don't
put more than 5 million worth of real
estate in one llc i open a different llc
okay so like i've got some houses as an
example and i'll total up the houses
when it gets to be about five million
dollars worth of houses
in rental properties i form another llc
and so i've got multiple llc's i don't
even own my cars i don't own anything
anymore
nothing is in my name
good luck
sue me yeah that's where
that's where we're at the only thing me
and my wife own personally is a personal
checking account yeah and maybe we
should get that out yeah because there
are idiots out there and there is a lot
there's two lawyers for every idiot
that's the problem you've got and so you
got a target on your butt because you
managed to become successful in this
economy it's aggravating as crud but
it's the reality so you you carry large
lumps of liability insurance lots of
umbrellas lots of general liability
insurance policies and your operational
policies that kind of thing and you
don't put more than
you you keep your assets
the target size small so if an idiot
gets drunk and falls off the front porch
one of these rental properties and
decides it's my fault that he got drunk
and fell off the porch
and sues us
then he might get those four houses but
he's not getting nothing else
and that's if he gets all the way
through the umbrella policies and
everything else and gets past me being
pissed off and funding the lawyer to
kick his drunk butt but i'll do that too
but aside from that the actual you know
the actual thing of the size of the
target has been diminished because i
once it gets to a certain size i i just
build another one
yup yup
can i ask one question on that point you
made one last one okay so
if you make sure one llc let's say it's
it's no more worth than than four to
five million and you have general
liability for four to five million i
understand if they see you for 50 i'll
get that well you're just going to hand
them the keys if you lose
walk away yeah exactly we're now in the
gas station good luck with that
have you ever gotten a personal
general liability policy on what you own
personally even though it's in the trust
i don't own anything additional
insurance
okay because it's all in the trust yeah
no it's all in a trust it's all in an
llc i don't own a thing
yeah except the interest in these
different companies
but that you know so any
anything we own personally that's not in
the trust we need to make sure we're
getting that stuff in the trust yeah
i started buying my cars and llc's
you know my lake house is in an llc
uh
everything so uh because of these idiots
that are out there running around
thinking that you owe them something
because you became successful it's just
the world we live in there's a bunch of
evil people out there
and yeah we had we've had we've had to
put cameras on all of our trucks front
sides and backs because we literally had
people pull in front of us and slam on
the brakes and then try to sue us oh yes
yep for sure i mean i i you know can you
imagine me bumping into to you and
coming up and going oh you know sorry
about that uh here's my insurance and
they go uh oh dave ramsey oh god and
they fall on the ground and you know and
start foaming at the mouth i mean this
is why i carry a 10 million dollar
liability umbrella you know because of
this this stuff it's just sad it's not
funny really but it's just it's the
world we live in and uh it's one of the
expenses that you have to take on
protect and to protect yourself and it's
just it's risk management categories
what it falls into you're just risk
management so big chunks of insurance
where you can and keep the bite size
tart keep the target bite-sized instead
of a whole buffet
yeah makes perfect sense
cool that was a fun discussion you got
to have that one on the air before i've
talked to my friends about that stuff
but this is it we're nerd now now yeah
we're completely nerded now with the
right kind of insurance enough i was
tuning into the ramsey show yeah you did
yeah diversify your risk portfolio there
you go i mean that's that's exactly what
we've done and uh smart get to review
that again tomorrow night in the estate
plan oh good this is a warm-up the monty
python
meeting the i'm feeling much better i'm
really not it's a pleasure to die
meeting so dave's gonna die this year
meeting i think you're gonna outlive us
all day just out of spite dadgum right
just dadgum right count on it george
that puts this hour of the ramsey show
in the books
[Music]
do you love a good dave rant want to see
the latest ramsay show videos going
viral check out your favorite moments
from the ramsay show on youtube go watch
and subscribe to the ramsay show channel
on youtube
[Music]
you